through I want to start with you I'm
just curious when you set out to write
this book how did you manage to tap all
of these memories that must have been so
hidden deep down um well the first thing
mom did was like I'm going to send you
off to peak hits the road away from here
just in your own time and and the and I
was there for two weeks and and that's
pretty much where I started it was
probably a good idea to just sort of
Adamo environment of being at home in
Hobart Tasmania and being somewhere else
and and some of the things I did was
when I first started was just listening
to music and and relax some more
chill-out kind of music and that helped
sort of you know tap in even further to
those closed doors that had a lot of
cobwebs and chains around them and in it
somehow just opened them and we got sort
of deeper and deeper hence when one door
was open another door
with sort of opening as well any sort of
go deeper and deeper into the story of
that particular part of my life so it
was a very very interesting you know
process but I'm sort of just glad that
those memories were still there which I
sort of been very endearing to me Ian
how did you discover this story how did
you to connect with each other
well the story itself was creating quite
a lot of waves in Australia and actually
internationally and I run my company
with the mill Sherman who's an
Australian and we just we know our aim
is to make in session stories but
definitely to try making social stories
where I'm from in the UK and where he is
from Australia so we heard about Saru
story when I just we just got to get
hold of that and we were sort of between
LA and Sunday
and gasps episodes of top of the lake
with Jane's episodes the top leg was
screening at Sundance Film Festival and
Emil just raced off back to Sydney
basically to try and convince zaroon and
his family to trust us and they did look
for you was basically everything that
you needed in the book and if not what
kind of conversations did you and Saru
have to flesh everything out in your
mind almost everything was in the book
but not really it was important for me
to meet
Saru and to travel to the various places
where all of these events happened when
I got the job it was basically like
you've got the job go fly to India and
meet Saru he's there right now we
traveled around India to all the real
places where all the events happened we
spent time with his mother that was both
a beautiful land a slightly distressing
experience for me because I sat there
with an interpreter and and and just
every single question I asked her for
two hours what made her weep even more
she wept and wept and wept but she was
very positive and she kept saying no I
kept apologizing and she kept saying no
no I want to do this I want to do this
it was a very emotional meeting Saru and
his mother just sat there like just
stroking each other and clutching each
other and and then I went to Tasmania I
met the met his adoptive parents and saw
what his life was like in Tasmania so
all of that really fleshed out stuff
that was in the book just in particular
getting to ask through in more detail
about what he what was going on for him
emotionally at certain events here's a
question for Sonny do you think you
would be as brave as Saru was yes yeah
why my best he's the best
I am my best
yes he's pretty much the best Nicole you
and I spoke about how the two of you
bonded and not sharing a language it
just was spending time together what do
you remember about what you found was
useful to create a connection with sunny
cricket hey he likes cricket and Garth
Davis who we all wish could be here
today because some he's obviously the
director and this was his first film I
always loved saying that yes but he was
the one that said the way to connect to
both sunny and then the boy that would
played montage is through cricket so I
started playing cricket um
and soccer a little bit of kicking the
ball around then yeah
and um and that was sort of that was the
weigh-in with him because obviously you
know he's not an actor so trying to UM
just gain his trust in his affection and
I'll you know for him to even let me
pick him up and all of that and just
even touch him always and be his mother
I had to build all of that and that was
through a different way you know whereas
with dev it was just like I'm your mum
but yeah so we did actually have a long
rehearsal process which was which was
fantastic that Garth fought for that
because it was so necessary and it
encompass many different facets and it
was very unusual but you see all of what
we did in the rehearsals somehow has
bled into the
it says in the film dev is it safe to
say you've never wanted a part more
you've never fought as hard for a role
as you did for this one yeah in fact I
turned up on the doorstep of Luke Luke's
house in Koreatown when him and Garth
was still writing the script and you
know I went in for this meeting and Luke
was like do not look at that whiteboard
it's classified information
they still had the debate points of the
characters and even finished the first
act but a look
you know characters like this don't come
around every often for people that look
like me you know it so it's really a
once-in-a-lifetime role it was there was
a pleasantly awkward meeting yeah it was
like oh hi so all of our agents have
said that we should have this meeting
okay I want a cup of tea legit ginger
tea remember yeah and then they kind of
yeah booted me out so they could get on
with writing this thing so it was an
unannounced visit no it was kind of I
heard of the story and uh I was just so
inspired you know by this guy's
resilience and you know it's the such a
beautiful message to be putting out into
the world and something that I really
wanted to help breathe life into but uh
you know Garth Garth was he popped me
through the ringer and I first Skyped to
them after that from my bathroom in Los
Angeles because it's the best reception
in it and then from there I went on to
audition for it in London it was a
mammoth six hour process before we came
out of it and you know you know here we
go well look I mean as I've asked you
before I thing that's so brilliant about
your screenplay is that like Saru
searched the screenplay leaves these
bread crumbs for the audience at these
wonderful lovely emotional moments when
Saru is at the dinner with his friends
and sees the jalebis I mean I just
completely lost it the first time I
watched the movie and then every time
you see has these discoveries there's
another great heartwarming moment was
that important to you structuring it out
is that why you had a whiteboard in as
far as mapping out when these moments
would appear yeah it seemed to me from
the very beginning that there was this
that I was very privileged to get this
job
because there was an opportunity to tell
this story which is extraordinarily
elemental like a very primal fable about
reunification with the lost mother and
that story must go back to the earliest
origins of human emotion because the one
thing I think that we all share an
absolutely universal common is that we
know what the utter vulnerability of the
infant is all of us even those of us who
never have a mother and and therefore
the desire for safety and security which
is the the emotional underpinning of
this film is the journey toward that
wholeness that safety that security with
that in mind it became it was a pleasure
to sort of sprinkle in all the seeds and
the moments and and that Gela be moment
was very overtly you know as Marcel
Proust in search of lost time the moment
with the Madeleine where he takes the
bite and the past floods back to him in
marcel proust case then for a
seven-volume extended novel of us cuts
back in our case for one hour and 42
minutes Nicole I know for you presenting
this story of motherhood is is very
important and one of the main the things
you're most excited about also adoption
stories to me always get me and two of
your children are adopted so I'm sure
this spoke to you on a double level how
would you describe what you're excited
to bring forward with this as a mother
and as a mother of adopted children I
mean as Luke said the essence of the
film is is the return to the mother the
power of mothers and I think you know
being a biological mother and an
adoptive mother it's some it's something
I love to explore but that the essence
to this role is that being the adoptive
mother the embracing of the birth mother
because we're connected and my favorite
line in the whole film is when he's
shown me all of the the wall on all of
the information and what he's put
together and he thinks
that he's going to hurt his son so and
she says no I I want her to see how
beautiful you are
and I wish you'd told me earlier because
I think that is so exquisite in its
emotion because that's the love that's
the unconditional love and and so we'll
say that I mean it really is that it's
it's everything and that is the love of
the child and also when he says you know
you could have had children of your own
and you've got me you've got us man
Tasha and I and she's like what are you
talking about
I wanted you I'm your mother and I love
that too because I think that so really
people see things a lot of times with
adoptive mothers in a particular way and
when you enter into the psychology from
a different angle you it on ppens you
and so I'm just very very proud to be
able to and I was so glad that when sue
saw her she was so embracing of it
because obviously it's very hard and
Sarah will tell you this to see yourself
interpreted on screen by somebody else
and probably the most important thing is
that she feels embracing of the
portrayal I think I speak for everyone
when I just say thank you for sharing
your story and thanks to all of you for
bringing it to the screen
congratulations everyone